salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero salas Ya está lista con
nosotros en el estudio para hablar de un
método innovador mar para controlar el
dengue y otras enfermedades aquí en
Colombia Buenos días Raúl cuéntame cuál
es el animal más mortífero del mundo
crees Yo creería que el mosquito por
chiquito y minuto que parezca e
inofensivo en algunos casos no doy fe de
que esta respuesta no se la tuve que
decir antes lo sabía lo sabía solo Raúl
tienes toda la razón del mundo sobre
todo es por las por las enfermedades que
transmiten los vectores los mosquitos
son vectores de infinitud de
enfermedades y Precisamente hay un
programa a nivel mundial se llama World
mosquito program que intenta pues
ponerle remedio a eso en varias partes
del mundo en América Latina en México y
en Brasil además en Colombia y tuvimos
la suerte con Juanita González
camarografa de ir a conocerlo la idea
detrás de su proyecto de su programa que
nació en Australia de la cabeza digamos
de Scott o'neal es controlar de formas
muy innovadoras este mosquito ae que es
el mosquito que transmite el dengue el
zika el chikungunya en otras partes del
mundo también la Fiebre amarilla qué es
lo que hacen cogen estos mosquitos y los
infectan con una bacteria común que se
encuentra en muchos otros tipos de
insectos que se llama la bacteria o el
vaquia compite con por recursos digamos
con estos virus que también transmite el
mosquito gana digamos no los deja crecer
no los deja no los Deja prosperar y por
lo tanto ese mosquito ya no puede
transmitir ese virus cuando pica a otra
persona Cuál es además La magia de todo
esto que cuando un mosquito con huelgas
Perdón se reproduce con un mosquito
normal la descendencia también ya tendrá
esta bacteria entonces así poco a poco
progresivamente se van generando
poblaciones de mosquitos que no pueden
transmitir enfermedades como el al
dengue como el chikungunya o como el
chica como ahora se lleva a la práctica
toda esta idea claro Primero lo primero
que tengo que hacer es criar millones de
mosquitos así no un mosquitos con
huelvaquia por ejemplo en los
laboratorios de Medellín que pudimos
visitar se crean al menos se generan a 7
millones de mosquitos semanales pero
tienen la capacidad para hacerlo 40
millones de mosquitos por cada semana
aquí vemos algunas de esas imágenes que
pudimos grabar y luego esto se tiene que
ir liberando en las ciudades de forma
precisa y consistente no midiendo muy
bien En qué zonas se está haciendo
Sabiendo cuántos hay en cada momento en
cada lugar y aproximadamente después de
20 semanas de liberar de esta forma
regular
mosquitos con huelva que allí se
reproducen al cabo de un año la
población la mitad más o menos de la
población de mosquitos que hay en esa
zona ya son mosquitos que están
protegidos contra estas enfermedades y
que no pueden transmitir los virus a las
personas esto ya se ha hecho en Medellín
ahora se está liberando estos mosquitos
en Cali y el resultado es que tienes eso
ciudades blindadas no a este tipo de
enfermedades
hecho en Cali están usando un método muy
innovador que pudimos conocer con este
drone que están viendo aquí y nos
explicaban precisamente Pues cómo
funcionaba
sí los mosquitos se cargan en un
mecanismo los mosquitos se cargan
refrigerados son las temperaturas Bajas
para poder cargarlos en el mecanismo el
mecanismo automatizado y este mecanismo
que va en el dron o va también en
vehículos terrestres en otras comunas en
la comuna 10 por ejemplo de Cali va
liberando cada ciertos metros cada 50
metros va liberando un número
determinado de mosquitos estamos muy
contentos con los desarrollos y los
avances que hemos tenido porque nos está
dando una distribución muy uniforme
vemos que los mosquitos llegan con un
buen fitness con un sobreviven digamos
en todo este proceso mar los resultados
que da este método vamos a revisar las
cifras de Medellín aunque ya se sabe
porque se ha hecho ya en otros lugares
del mundo que tiene resultados positivos
y la incidencia de dengue vamos a
revisar es decir los casos de dengue por
cada 100.000 habitantes en Medellín
bajaron un 47% En comparación con las
zonas que no estaban protegidas con
walvaquia con mosquitos que tenían la
volvaquia en total pero es que además en
barrios con más cobertura donde la
cobertura era ya prácticamente total de
este tipo de mosquitos la incidencia del
dengue bajo en un 73% Respecto a los que
pues transcurrían con normalidad con una
población normal de mosquitos esto es un
resultado además al cabo de tan poco
tiempo verdaderamente esperanzador si lo
comparamos también con todo lo que
sucede en Colombia no el dengue tiene
picos estacionales va subiendo y va
bajando con los tiempos Pues con las
dinámicas propias de las enfermedades
infecciosas y vemos por ejemplo aquí no
como la línea oscura es Medellín la
línea más Clarita es Colombia
coincidieron a más o menos esos picos
pero por ejemplo el último al cuando nos
acercamos al 2020 en Medellín ni
siquiera sucedió y de hecho 2021 ha sido
el año con menos casos de dengue en
Medellín desde que se cuentan en las
últimas dos décadas mientras que
Colombia entera ya ha registrado Solo
este año 50.000 casos es decir que
sabemos que hoy en día está funcionando
Cuáles son los pasos a seguir Pues por
supuesto La idea es que Cuanto más mejor
Cuantos más mosquito mejores también en
términos de innovación de hecho nos
contaban que este método con el dron de
liberar estos mosquitos que es la
primera vez que se hace pues a esta
escala en zonas urbanas la idea también
es poder exportarlo
esa Innovación que estamos desarrollando
en Cali La idea es en la medida que
funciona en la medida que logramos
ajustar toda la operación y a la medida
que vemos la eficiencia que tiene pues
poderla desarrollar en diferentes
lugares del mundo donde el proyecto ha
trabajado hasta el momento el proyecto
ha desarrollado acciones en 11 países y
ya protegido a más de 10 millones de
personas en todo el mundo y la idea con
esta Innovación es poder dar ese salto
cualitativo que nos permita llegar a
muchas más personas a proteger mucho más
comunidades alrededor del mundo habla de
proteger a estas comunidades además
recordemos que este tipo de enfermedades
suele afectar a los barrios más
empobrecidos por las dinámicas sociales
que tienen también de almacenamiento de
agua entonces la idea además es
especialmente innovadora porque resulta
ena no intentar controlar la población
de los mosquitos no intentar combatirlos
por ejemplo con insecticidas que también
tiene un impacto grave en otros tipos de
insectos o en poblaciones en las plantas
también entonces esa es la idea
conseguir blindar el máximo de ciudades
por ejemplo un mosquito programa ahora
quiere hacer un laboratorio que pueda
ser itinerante en varias ciudades de
Colombia para ir haciendo el mismo
proyecto y además también de cara al
futuro sabemos que el cambio climático
va a traer que los mosquitos crezcan Al
menos que sean mosquitos Pues que están
vacunados digamos de enfermedades
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información mañana con más salud
mañana con más